Final Fantasy 15 Yesi the story that
will not stop given the delays that will
not stop happening alexa ray corriea and
has been delayed once more 10 years in
the making what's two more months Yeah
right what does do more once you didn't
seem at all you know put off by this God
you were just like screaming screaming
into your palms for most of Sully
morning I guess no sulking my way into
the office I don't know I didn't expect
that I know a lot of people did but I
didn't they've just been hammering on it
for so long and they've shown so much
and like from what they've shown there
was like the boss fight at e3 and
they've had the two demos they've been
like showing story stuffing the anime in
the film and I thought all right it's
coming together like the films coming
out games coming out a month after mmm
no I mean it yeah it was a it's I don't
think it was any wrong and assuming it
was going to come as they even like has
quite a large press conference the
ending of which was the release finish
where they jokingly predicted when the
game would be delayed till it stopped so
there was like a real that had the
months on it and it stopped and it went
and it clicked september-october
November for a beat it was on November
and then switched back to september's in
November 30th oh yeah hitting me yeah so
one day Wow he predicted their own delay
also Greg Miller when he brought the
button out and he was like it's delayed
again and greg did it hey at least we
could say we didn't launch we didn't
leak the race day now the real really we
were we were just Jojo joking the whole
time september's sorry November 29th is
now when it's coming out yes it was
original coming at September 30th yes
right and November 29th Alexa it's quite
late in what we consider to be like the
holiday season yeah white on the tan and
right it's it's the week right after
Thanksgiving so guess what we'll be
doing thanksgiving weekend hopefully um
she wants to go home no not anymore uh
no but it's like just late enough that
it kind of is like on the cutoff of like
does this get included in like Game of
the Year consideration just get included
for the game awards it's get included in
the GCC awards it's like right at the
end and everything's out already
except for like South Park i think is
the only game coming out into some yeah
it's the one big one that comes to mind
anyway that's the thing i guess is that
usually all the big games Peter come out
before Black Friday it seems to be yeah
I remember working in retail most of the
big game seem to be at like first week
in november second week in november and
then like someone the third but they
were pretty much all out by them because
so many people get their their holiday
shopping done and what do you think when
you see a date like that is that is that
too late is it is it this type of game
that's gonna sell no matter when it
comes out anyway i think too late for
Final Fantasy 10 came here 15 came along
too yeah they this game has been a long
time coming i think anyone who's
interested in it is not going to be
swayed by I mean maybe some people but
they're not going to swayed by like a
new advertisement focused around the
holiday season I mean they've been
looking forward to this game for a long
time and there's been a lot of fanfare
like you mentioned you know like a lot
of events a lot of announcements and
people have had a lot of opportunity to
decide if they want this game already
and for as much as we want final fantasy
you know we think of it as this big
brand right but mainstream people don't
necessarily I don't think right so it's
like place to our generation probably
quiet maybe yeah I mean it's I guess I'm
saying is it's not like a call of duty
right where if people don't already like
Final Fantasy they're probably not going
to get into this now so they've probably
already made up their mind so I don't
think that the date is going to make or
break the success of this game I'm dobbs
worth in seven saying that at that
rising for also coming at in December is
ah South Park christmas-themed as well
so fair play and Alexa so the end of
november how are you feeling about the
game because obviously this is a game
the yourself and peter of big fans of
the franchise you've been covering it a
lot I'm over the past couple of years
here at gamespot com how are you feeling
about it when you see delay like this
it's an extra two months that make you a
little bit more worried about the
project does it make you feel like hey
at least they're like what not extra bit
of polish on so I'm always of the mind
that if a developer realizes from what I
understand I've know a lot people in
game dev making the call to delay a game
is a lot of conversation between dev
team and marketing and it's a hard
trigger to pull so this decision was not
made lightly and if you need that extra
time like good on you for recognizing
that you need it and for taking it and
like I would understand
they pushed out the game as is on
September 30th and then had like a
massive patch or something because
because that's what people are expecting
but to say that they want more time to
deliver a better product like okay like
like that's fine like I'm still gonna
buy I'm still going to play it I think
it's good that they took the time I am
somewhat concerned a little bit less
about maybe the quality of the product
but I don't know if you watched the
message from Hajime Tabata the director
yeah he looked like so I've like seen
him many many times over the past two
years we talked a lot he's like super
ripped and is like a very healthy guy
and he like sexy he looked a little
skinny and he looked really tired and um
and he's like basically taken over this
is a couple years ago he took it over
from Tetsuya Nomura who's now working on
kingdom hearts and is supervising the
Final Fantasy 7 remake and like when
Tabata was saying we've made the
decision and he was ramping up to the
sentence saying we've delayed the game
and his pauses were getting longer and
longer and he would drop his eyes and
he'd take a deep breath and I'm like
this decision was not made right like I
believe that that team is like putting
they're putting their all into it and I
hope that like they are okay like going
into this final push I know this has
been like a some people that have been
working on that game have been working
at it since it was versus 13 so this has
been the past 11 years of their life I
mean there's quite a bit of reputation
on the line here oh yeah thank you games
that have a rocky they're technically
rocky at start be it frame rate or
whatever people sort of latch onto that
and that becomes the story and if the
story is we waited 10 years for this
mess rocket I think the game is a mess
but if they have anything to be
concerned about I cannot blame them for
wanting to at least make sure they're
delivering something that meets people's
expectations it definitely seems like a
project that's like a massive like
uphill struggle especially for somebody
who decided who decided to take it over
like oh yeah even as if this was just
something like it's kind of like that
you know in a way it's like a poison
pill where they I don't know they have
to make it so good to make sure that
people get over that I'm so I'm not a
massive final fantasy fan I played
little bit of seven I'm not reading into
the series and I'm everyday history our
video years ago and had to get mark
Walton to write us because I can't even
figure out all this this is the escaping
mount stupid yes so yeah yeah yeahs
two-parter
of final fantasy games out there and but
I have been sort of interested in this
because of the sort of more action
orientated thing or at least it looks a
bit closer to games that I do play and
however looking at the e3 demo and
especially I was kind of looking at you
guys to your reactions of that and I was
starting to get a little bit skeptical
so I think you know they obviously had a
bit of a rough demo perhaps because of
some latency issues of the person
playing it perhaps because of the design
of it do you think maybe this delay is
anything to do with them looking at that
and going you know maybe we need to put
a little bit more time into shoring up
here this place um so that demo played
like they what it felt like to me is
they took the boss fight from the game
they pulled it out and it Final Fantasy
boss fights can go on for like hours
depending on how complicated they are
and these look fairly complicated if
you're battling these giant monsters and
it felt to me like they took the the
boss fight out of the game and said okay
we can't have people standing at demo
kiosks for an hour how do we make it
shorter and they literally pulled out
like phase 2 and phase 3 and this and
that and like go straight to the
QuickTime event it felt like they felt
like they pulled all the elements out
and just made it shorter and I don't
think that that demo was indicative at
all of anything that's going to be in
the game I think that was like we made
this especially for the show to show you
how things look and how combat feels and
they didn't do a very good job maybe
they were brushed under time constraints
I think this delay has everything to do
with the fact that Peter net we're
talking about this yesterday in the
video Tabata explains like well we could
release the game but with a patch and
the problem with the patch is they don't
want to release a game of the day one
patch because fans that by the disc
version that don't have an internet
connection or a solid internet
connection won't have the best
representation of the game right so they
want to delay the game so that that day
one patch is like on the disc and like
totally together and that's the full
package that comes out on the first day
I don't I can't think of any other big
Japanese games that do day one patches
that seems like a really good idea
Western is it a Western yeah yeah that's
interesting so I guess they just want to
make sure that that version me explain
he detailed what a patch is in the video
as high for watching it are like totally
foreign to that concept do you think
that a lot of Japanese
don't necessarily have I mean I don't
want to generalize right big cities then
there are a lot of people live you know
further and the country and also you
know yeah yeah that is a reality over
there as well and okay I mean I thought
we were done doing videos about fun
fantasy 15 mins late hopefully you know
maybe we are final thoughts on this
though Peter what do you think what are
your expectations of 15 it seems to me
like a game that I feel like there are
some games where people they are happy
to buy it happy to play a game
regardless of the reviews or first
impression scores or anything like that
and to me this feels like a game that I
think everyone's going to be looking for
the review straight away to see how it
went at what are your serve expectations
on phonathon 15 I think that there's
going to be a lot of elements that are
handled really well and that are
surprising I mean a lot of final fantasy
games you know live and die by their
surprises and but also their
storytelling and so I think what I'm
worried about is perhaps the writing and
maybe not so much the voiceovers but at
least the writing that's led to the
lines of dialogue that I've heard isn't
very creative believable and if we're
supposed to be following a troop of you
know guys who really know each other
very well they should be able to mesh
with one another and I have not gotten
that sense like the way that they play
with one another sure but the way that
they talk to each other right not so
much and so I'm really worried I guess
about how the characters work together
in the story I think the more
interesting story will probably be
without the team all right you're
controlling so I'm very optimistic but I
definitely have some concerns so Alexa
um I so uh sort of bringing in another
final fantasy 15 thing here my review
for the film went up yesterday cave
comes out in theaters this week end of
the month on digital and they did some
really good storytelling McCain slave
grant of you kind of need to know what's
going on in the larger Final Fantasy 15
universe understand but it was good and
like the dialogue was really good and
like the characterization was great the
way that the characters played off each
other I really enjoyed it and that made
me hopeful for 15 story cuz it's a seems
like 15 s cast is quite large the thing
that I am sort of reserving any judgment
on is the world and the world building
because we've only seen like the same
three or four locations over
over and over and over and over and I'm
wondering just how big that world is
like if you look in the footage that
came out today you can see kind of the
edges of a map but we keep going back
and forth from like one city to another
to like the the dusk idemo that region
we keep going back there and then we
keep going back here and then we keep
going back there and I just I just want
i'm concerned about how big it is
because so many other final fantasy
games like ten comes to mind and six
comes to mind like you had like a giant
world to explore with like an airship so
that's probably the last thing i'm a
little reserved on yeah fingers crossed
I'm very excited for it yeah hopefully
I've got too much longer to wait this
year I'm fantasy 15 coming out November
29th